we will do everything together
in partnership in solidarity
to support what is necessary at this
very moment
in terms of the humanitarian and
security needs
of ukraine and the ukrainian people
vice president kamala harris out in
poland and doing her best to clean up
the big mess over fighter jets for
ukraine the biden administration
claiming a breakdown in communication as
the reason for them blocking the deal
that would have gotten ukrainians the
air defense capabilities desperately
needed to fight off the russian invasion
harris claiming the u.s is united with
poland despite the disconnect even
dodging a question about it
what kind of alternative plans does the
united states have
to get materials to help ukraine defend
itself
especially now that you have declined
poland's offer on jets i want to be very
clear
the united states and poland
are united
in what we have done
and are prepared to do
to help ukraine and the people of
ukraine
full stop
and the vice president's visit to europe
is apparently all for show according to
politico white house officials say
harris is not there to make any deals
but merely as a symbol of the
administration's commitment to ukraine
what harris did however was bring
awkward moments like this
and for president judah i wanted to know
if you think and if you asked the united
states to specifically accept more
refugees
okay
a friend in need is a friend indeed
jesse i'll go to you
why did they even send her
well hunter was busy
hunter yes
so snotty so sorry geraldo
i don't know whether she didn't know
that she was being called upon or
couldn't answer the question
because she would just ask will you guys
accept refugees right she always accepts
refugees she's never said no to
accepting refugees
and she couldn't handle it and she
tossed it to the polish president that
was strange to then cackle and laugh
during a time of crisis like this
putin's got to be looking at this
and saying to himself and he's kgb this
does not look like a united front when
you have a kerfuffle amateur hour with a
polish jet that's a fiasco biden
apparently said yes send jets and then
the pentagon said no we can't do it so
biden said it was the polish president's
idea
and so she goes over there and it's a
word salad i counted some phrases and
were paid to speak for a living so we
know when someone has no idea what
they're talking about you're the expert
i am
in three sentences this is this is what
she said to the extent
in terms of in light of in particular
and as it relates to
there was a guy on social media i think
matt walsh was his name he said kamala
sounds like she's trying to hit the word
count for a term paper remember in high
school you just had to get it to 300
words that's how she sounds so i'm sick
of them
saying nothing and
i would actually like biden especially
to stop saying what he won't do i know
people have said that before but why not
keep putin guessing why not maybe say
you know what we might actually we're
not taking anything off the table you
know maybe you buzz some jets over the
russian border maybe you throw some subs
into the black sea maybe you pay putin's
girlfriend to visit in switzerland
you knock on the door of the chalet
maybe deliver a bouquet of roses maybe
the c.i.a writes a little something in
the note
i'll see you in the hague get in his
head because right now
putin doesn't what's he have two weeks
to surround the capital zielinski's in
deep trouble if he can't hold these guys
off soon and it's you know they're gonna
starve them out and they're gonna send
in assassins we don't have a lot of time
we have to do something
more than we're doing right now well you
know dana given the fact that she
doesn't even have the cape the ability
to say yes we will accept refugees when
she's in charge of the border uh is is
really it's stunning i mean she has the
like the intellectual horsepower of a
fourth grader i mean
why is she there didn't she know that
she'd be asked these questions i
um i wouldn't i think that she was sent
there
on a mission that was destined to fail
and this has happened again and again to
her intentionally no not necessarily i
think that because of the administration
is just like at cross purposes at once
she was like she was going to go to
poland because she was going to deliver
some something tangible and then when
she gets there after the fact they say
actually no she's just there to show a
symbolic relationship now her
performance was very much not tear down
this wall
okay it was better than john kerry
taking james taylor to france
but she does
she gets there so she doesn't have a
deliverable to say the migs are going to
get to ukraine
but not only did she not have a
deliverable she didn't know the answer
to the question about why the migs
aren't going right
and that's the most important thing that
you she could have done today is provide
clarity on that now instead we're on the
third day of everyone saying help us
understand
javelins are okay to send the patriot
missile system that all of that is okay
but the migs are not
that might be a good decision but could
you explain it to us and they are not
able to do that
she
should not have taken the assignment if
she wasn't going to be able to deliver
something or she should have said i've
got an idea why don't we deliver this x
y or z or she could have said the
refugees are welcome they just got to
get through mexico first
all right
go ahead greg
i'll just write something down thinking
i probably can't say that you know what
look she could get she could become
very sensitive i'll ask you this harold
she's women
as the children are at play are you
ready
go ahead are you ready no go ahead okay
she can get very excited about ice and
she can liken them to the kkk and she
can be very knowledgeable about
surfboards and then all of a sudden
she's clueless on the national and the
international stage i think that
you hit on something legitimate with
that criticism because she seemed meek
and unsure to dennis point uh she didn't
go there with any kind of decisiveness
whether or not she had a deliverable she
could have been optimistic for example
we saw a stunning video today of uh
apparently unless someone contradicts or
say it was staged of the ukrainian
special forces ambushing a russian tank
column with their javelin missiles and
tank after tank or with the drones tank
after tank blowing up russian tank after
russian tank going up she should have
been this
we're getting them the fight is on and
uh zielinski's doing a great job and
this is the alamo and we should
celebrate their their courage and their
patriotism a little zest a little
optimism instead of going there and
nervous laughter uh that that's off cue
and uh you know it just it seems
you know i i want i want to love her i
want her to be the historic figure that
she's not but she's uh she's
she's not living up to who geraldo you
can't change you can't you can't but but
you can still aspire and and and my
headline with that my kids are okay
my headline is that the ukrainians ain't
beat yet and we're helping them fight
and and putin is thinking man maybe this
wasn't such a good idea
is that what putin's thinking greg i
think that putin realizes that we're not
in it to win it
right we wouldn't have sent her she's
great for us this show but she's lousy
for this job she makes us laugh but her
laugh is so unsettling because it wasn't
she wasn't laughing about it an obvious
thing that other people could see it was
also it was an inside joke of sorts so
it just is kind of like what are they
doing up there right now i don't
understand it she's like a child she's
on a big trip she's like a child who's
allowed to see the cockpit but you
better not touch anything please don't
touch any of the buttons she's not
allowed to have any any impact on
anything because she's not to be you
know they don't trust her she is right
now a polish joke and i love that she
said full stop but um yeah but you think
when you
now that's the that's the unserious
stuff the serious stuff and the sad part
is this is
a symbolic virtue signal that is
replacing real activity we do not need
this sort of emblem is what she was
referred to she's an emblem of our
concern we need a shocking audacious
diplomatic effort and we need it swiftly
i've talked about it before you know
we've said we spent a lot of time and
billions of dollars in the ukraine now
they need us
we got to send our very best there not
the joker in a pant suit we need obama
we need trump we need bush they gotta go
one or two the combination because we
need mediation on steroids that
expresses how much the world is
disgusted by this and how
intent we are on stopping the bloodshed
and potential world war three without
that by doing this this only prolongs it
this prolongs the suffering and and it
makes us look like we don't care can i
add one other thing is that she the she
had a message to send to the american
people right because we are all watching
um putin's watching but we haven't
talked about the ukrainian response and
their reaction to her speech was was
abysmal and
heralda you said she should have spoke
with optimism for them if you hanging on
every single word the administration
says and those were the words today
right you would not feel like you were
comforted you definitely needed defiance
yeah yeah and
she has i think failed and all of those
in any event with the humanitarian
crisis in ukraine getting worse many of
you are asking how you can help you can
join fox in supporting the red cross
relief efforts there donate now by going
to red cross dot org forward slash fox
forward over two million dollars has
been raised
and coming up horrific images of mass
graves in ukraine as russia claims that
their hands are completely clean
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else